hi everyone it's joanna here today's
workout is going to be a quick 20 minute
total body strength training so this
workout will work on all the major
muscles your legs your upper body as
well as your core so this workout will
challenge your muscular endurance as
well as your muscular strength so if
you're in a rush but you would still
like to get an awesome workout in then
be sure to join me
for this workout you'll need a pair of
medium weight dumbbells at least between
four to seven kilos each okay so let's
start
with a quick warm-up to prep our body
start right at the edge of your mat
alright let's get into some inch worms
slowly
inch forward keeping your knees bent
get into a full plank position now push
your butt back into a downward dog
back into a plank and slowly inch back
into standing
good
give me two more
and as you inch forward you can start to
keep your legs straight full plank
push your butt back into a downward dog
plank and slowly inch back
alright you should start to feel the
stretch on your hamstrings
each forward
push your butt back and up
down back into a plank
and
slowly inch up all right
okay now
give me some squats okay we will be
doing lots of squats so squat into
lunges stand shoulder width apart with
your toes pointed forward so push your
butt back
stand back up and
lunges
alternating between your legs
step back
squat
left leg back
squat
and right leg back good
two more on each side
squat down
lunge back
squat down
and one more squat
making sure that your chest is upright
and your back
flat good
all right now
few stretches okay so start in a high
plank position
bring your left leg forward and release
your left arm twist and look up
back into a high plank
right leg forward twist
and look up good so you should really
feel the stretch along your back
as well as your hip flexors
up
stretch
back down
good
let's release all the tight muscles
back up
one more on each side
up
and now slowly push yourself
back up
okay
few shoulder rotations
and we'll start the first
round okay
forward
back and just shake it out good job for
the first round we will work on your
lower body okay so grab the dumbbells
the first workout is going to be a squat
with a press
so place the dumbbells just by your
shoulders
all you want to do is squat down and as
you come up
push your arms straight up
into a shoulder press
good job so remember
nice and controlled movement
avoid using too much momentum okay
again this is a full body
strength training workout so we're
working on the entire body using
compound movements press straight up
back down
and remember to breathe out
as you press the dumbbells up down
press up
back down
last two more
give me one more
squat
and up good job
now do you feel your legs on fire do you
feel your shoulders on fire that's what
we want
next we will be working on your left leg
to begin with and then on your right
side so start in a kneeling position
all i want to do is
drive yourself up in
into a squat position lower your left
knee
bring it up okay
so
you should feel
the tension
and the work
on your right leg
good job so this is actually a strength
progression workout
if you have been doing your regular
strength routine at home this workout is
a great way to really progress
and really
hitting
the leg muscles right here good job
on fire my glutes
my thighs i can feel it
one more
and
stand back up just shake it out
all right
are we ready to change to the other side
okay
short break
start in a kneeling position and we want
to push yourself up into a squat okay
ready
put yourself up into a squat
lower your right knee
tap
and up okay so always remember to keep
yourself low
and this time you should feel
the work
on your left
thighs and glutes
good job there you go
remember to pace your breathing
stay low
if this is too much drop
the weights okay
choose your option
if not
stay with me
less than 10 seconds
keep going
remember chest up do not lean forward
one last one
oh my gosh okay
drop the weights
we're not done okay we're going to end
each round with a quick 30 seconds
burnout so for this round it's going to
be in and out squat jump
oh catch your breath i told you it's
going to work on your endurance as well
now let's go
jump up tap
into a white squat
and tap
good job look straight ahead
look at the finishing line
we're almost at the end of round
one
keep going tap
stay low
last few more
two more
that's one more
and good job
shake it out
take a short break
and we will move in to the second round
focusing on your upper body
are we ready for round two
this is going to be your upper body
round so grab your weights the first
workout is going to be a renegade row so
let's get into a high plank position
okay
choose your option you can either
hold on to both dumbbells
and making sure that your back is flat
roll one dumbbell up towards your waist
pointing your elbow back
and gaze onto the floor
so this is going to work
on your back muscles
your shoulder stability as well as your
core okay remember
keep your back flat
spread your feet wider apart to
stabilize yourself and avoid dipping
your hips side to side
good job
if this is too much you can always place
your pumps onto the floor
okay
choose your option
and
release the dumbbells so drop the
dumbbells okay
next
again we'll be working on the left chest
and arm to begin with staggered push up
okay so place your left hand forward
right hand slightly back
choose your option either get onto your
knees
and slowly lower yourself down push
yourself up okay
so you should feel the work
on
the front
arm more
lower yourself and push yourself up if
this is too easy
then let's go for the challenge get onto
your toes
and push
good job
stagger push up
working
on one side
more good lower yourself push up
remember do not dip your hips do not
hike your butt up lower
up
that's one more
good job
oh my gosh
i told you it's going to be a strength
progression so we start off easy we
progress in the next exercise right now
right palms forward or the other palms
forward left palm back
you can start off easy
start on your knees
let's go down
up
down
and up okay so choose your option
everybody has their own starting point
and as you progress
get onto your toes
now let's go down
push yourself up again
breathe out
as you push
up halfway there
nice and controlled
there you go
oh my gosh
my chest
my arms
everything is burning one last one more
and drop back down okay
shake it a little bit
the final 30 seconds burn up it's going
so quickly so let's give it our all okay
it's going to be mountain climbers so
get into a high plank position
only 30 seconds drive your knees in
towards your chest
go
running up that hill let's go
push it
gaze onto the floor
come on one final bus towards the
finishing line
10 more seconds
push
keep going we're not stopping right now
three
two
one
and drop
oh my gosh
just like this we're done with the
second round
take a shot break and we're going back
to work on our lower body for round
three
[Music]
all right guys give your upper body a
short break now let's work on your lower
body again this time we want to focus on
your outer as well as your inner thighs
okay so grab your dumbbells stand in a
white squat position point your toes out
place the dumbbells in the middle squat
down
and push up remember to push your butt
back and down and push up through your
heels
up good job there you go
slowly one two
and up in one count
up
so you should feel the engagement on
your inner thighs as well as your outer
glutes push up
starting off easy
and you know that the second
exercise is going to be more challenging
a few more
really point your toes out your knees
out
and good job shake it out okay
the next exercise is going to be a side
lunge with your knees pointing up okay
so
start at one side of the mat as you take
a white step to the side
drive your knee up
okay
ready
one step to the side
bend your foot
and point your knees up
so this is going to work on your core
balance as well
again if this is too much
what you can do is
drop the weights
and just use your own body weight to
begin with
so work with what's challenging for you
up
and point up
good job
here you go
give me one more
and up
okay
all right
now
let's start on the other side of the mat
okay so now remember
what you want to do is
bend your left foot bringing the
dumbbells down this way as you come up
drive your left knee straight up okay
let's go left knee down
this is definitely a more
challenging side for me
up point
good
so nice and controlled movement
when it comes to strength training
remember that
you should not be rushing
through the exercise okay control
feel the squeeze
right at your outer glutes
and the stretch
on your inner thighs
point
lift it up
there you go
give me two more
and last one more
and up okay
drop the dumbbells
guess what's our final burnout again
working on your outer and inner thighs
it's going to be side to side shuffle
only 30 seconds long okay so let's start
on your left side let's go
shuffle to your right tap
double step
and tap
maintaining a low position
shuffling
to the left
and to the right
so we want to drive a heart rate up
to increase
fat
burn
good job
keep going
you're almost at the end
of round
three
last one
and up
oh my gosh
well done guys that is the end of round
three
take a short break drink some water and
we have one last round to go
[Music]
my heart rate is still high okay but
we're going to finish this workout
strong the final round is going to work
on your core as well as your upper body
so let's get down into a high plank
position the first exercise is going to
be spiderman plank
get into a high plank drive your knee
towards
the elbow okay so really point
your knee out
and feel the squeeze
on your obliques
point it out
good job
remember that whenever you're in a plank
position
your back should always be flat
if you're piking your butt up
then
drop your knees take a shot break and
get back into a high plank position okay
breathe out
as you point
your
knee
forward
that's two more one more
and
drop
oh my gosh
i am sweating my entire body is shaking
and this is going to be a really
challenging exercise
side plank
just on your elbow
and we want to
crunch okay so again working on your
obliques let's go reach out crunch
point it out
and crunch
okay
find your center
look at one focal point
and pace your breathing
i know it's hard
but guess what you're towards
the end of your workout so do not dip
your hips lift it high up
and crunch
point
and crunch
okay
it's not just
you working with your body
you're also working
with your mind
last two more crunch
one more
and drop
good job
okay
you know the drill
on the other side right now
so this is probably my weaker side okay
so get into
a side plank position
remember bring your hips up do not drop
your hip bring it up
point out
crunch out
crunch good job
okay final 40 seconds
stay with me
focus crunch in
there you go
well if i'm not talking
i guess you know that
it is a tough
exercise point and crunch remember
lift your hip up
do not drop your hip up
point
crunch
that's two more
balance
one more
and
oh my gosh
drop it right there
okay
can you see what i look like right now
this is a total body strength training
working on your endurance right now
final 30 seconds burnout
plank jacks okay
get into a high plank position
jump your foot out and yo
both feet in okay
out and in
nice and easy
final 30 seconds
and we're at the end of our workout
session
there you go
i can see that finishing line what about
you
only five seconds away
two
one
and
drop it back down
oh my gosh
amazing amazing effort that was a quick
20-minute total body strength training
and
before we go anywhere
let's just spend two to three weeks
three minutes to bring your heart rate
back down
and to cool down okay so
just get into a child's pose to begin
with push your butt back
and just relax
all right just breathe in
we've worked so hard so it is as
important
to cool down
and bring your heart rate back down
stay here for another 10 seconds
and just listen to your breath
all right now slowly push yourself back
up
okay
drive
one leg forward
and all i want to do is to
push
your hips forward and feel the stretch
on your right hip flexor
oh my gosh it is raining in here
and now twist
look as far back as you can
good job
and straighten the front leg
and feel the stretch on your hamstrings
[Music]
so just feel a comfortable stretch okay
do not over stretch
[Music]
and good now
change the other side
right leg forward
again push your hips forward feel the
stretch on your left hip flexor
alright reach up
and drop your arms down and twist
look as far back as you can
good job
and straighten the front leg
and just lower your body down and feel
the stretch
on your hamstring
[Music]
and now slowly push yourself back up
into standing position
okay
few
big arm circles just to end this workout
[Music]
back
and now give me three
deep breaths
breathe in
and release
breathe in
and release
one last one breathe in
stretch
and out
really really amazing job guys it's only
a quick 20 minute total body strength
training but as you can see i am
drenched in sweat and i'm feeling really
strong to kick start my day or to end my
day feeling really accomplished so if
you enjoyed this workout be sure to hit
the like button subscribe to my channel
if you haven't yet done it and check out
a lot more full body workout videos
cardio exercises as well as strength
training on my youtube channel and i
will see you in my next workout all the
best
[Music]
you